>>> THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
MAR-A-LAGO RESIDENCE SAW YET
GAIN UP CLOSE PERSONAL ACCESS TO
HIM THIS WEEK, LIZ COKEN A
PROMINENT QANON CONSPIRACY
SPEAKER.
AND KANYE WEST WHO HAS BEEN
MAKING A SLOUGH OF ANTI-SEMITIC
STATEMENTS AS WELL AS WHITE
SUPREMACIST NICK FUENTES.
IT RAISES A LOT OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHO GETS ENTRY AND CLOSE
ACCESS TO TRUMP WHICH BRINGS ME
TO SOMEONE ELSE SPOTTED AT
MAR-A-LAGO MULTIPLE TIMES LAST
YEAR AN ALLEGED FAKE HEIRESS WHO
CLAIMED TO BE FROM THE
ROTHSCHILD FAMILY AND IS NOW
UNDER INVESTIGATION BY THE FBI.
RANDI KAYE HAS NEW DEVELOPMENTS
TONIGHT.
>> SHE VERY CLEARLY VIEWS
HERSELF AS ANNA ROTHSCHILD AND
SHE KIND OF MAINTAINS THAT SHE
WAS PART OF THE FAMILY.
>> Reporter: HE IS TALKING ABOUT
THIS WOMAN WHOM HE THOUGHT WAS
ANNA DE ROTHSCHILD.
AN INVESTMENT BANKER AND GUEST
AT MAR-A-LAGO SAYS HE MET HER AT
THE CLUB LAST YEAR JUST BEFORE
MOTHER'S DAY AND SAYS SHE PASSED
HERSELF OFF AS PART OF THE
ROTHSCHILD FAMILY BANKING
DYNASTY AND CALLED IT A NEAR
PERFECT RUSE.
>> SHE TALKED ABOUT GROWING UP
IN MONTE CARLO, TALKED ABOUT HER
GRANDPARENTS' HOUSE IN WEST PALM
BEACH.
SHE TALKED ABOUT FAMILY
INVESTMENTS IN THE DOMINICAN
REPUBLIC.
AND THE BAHAMAS.
>> Reporter: THE PITTSBURGH POST
GAZETTE AND ORGANIZED CRIME AND
REPORTING PROJECT WERE THE FIRST
TO REPORT THE WOMAN'S ALLEGED
CAPER AT MAR-A-LAGO WHICH FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLS HOME.
THEY SAY SHE VISITED THERE AT
LEAST FIVE TIMES LAST YEAR.
NEW REPORTING BY THE GAZETTE AND
OCCRP HAS REVEALED POSSIBLE TIES
TO A RUSSIAN GANG ENTERPRISE
WITH A HISTORY OF MONEY
LAUNDERING.
THIS IS VIDEO THEY OBTAINED OF
HER DRIVING UP TO THE MAR-A-LAGO
CLUB'S FRONT DOORS.
>> SHE IS WEARING DESIGNER
CLOTHES.
SHE HAS THE GOLD ROLEX WATCHES.
SHE'S WEARING THE BRACELETS.
>> Reporter: THE POST GAZETTE
AND OCCRP REPORTED NUMEROUS
RECORDS HAVE BEEN TURNED OVER TO
THE FBI AS PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
THESE ARE JUST SOME OF THE FAKE
I.D.s THOSE MEDIA OUTLETS SAY
THE 33-YEAR-OLD WOMAN WAS
ALLEGEDLY USING.
TWO FAKE PASSPORTS.
ONE FROM THE U.S. AND ONE FROM
CANADA.
AND A FLORIDA DRIVER'S LICENSE
THAT USES THE HOME ADDRESS OF AN
$18 MILLION MANSION IN MIAMI
BEACH.
WHERE THE PITTSBURGH POST
GAZETTE SAYS SHE HAS NEVER
LIVED.
LOOK CLOSELY.
THE NAME ON ALL OF THEM IS ANNA
DE ROTHSCHILD BUT THAT WOMAN IS
NOT ANNA DE ROTHSCHILD.
HER REAL NAME IS INA YASHISHIN.
>> SHE IS DRIVING A BRAND NEW
MERCEDES G WAGON $170,000.
AND SHE HAS TRANSFORMED HERSELF
INTO ANNA DE ROTHSCHILD.
>> Reporter: WE USED HER REAL
IDENTITY TO TRACK DOWN HER
LAWYER.
SHE DECLINED OUR REQUEST FOR AN
ON CAMERA INTERVIEW BUT THROUGH
HER LAWYER TOLD US SHE HAD ONLY
COME HERE TO THE MAR-A-LAGO CLUB
ONCE ON MAY FIRST, 2021 WHEN
ASKED IF SHE CLAIMED TO BE A
ROTHSCHILD SHE SAID, SHE HAD
NEVER USED THE NAME INSIDE
MAR-A-LAGO AND NEVER HELD
HERSELF OUT AS THAT.
>> YOU KNOW, CATEGORICALLY FALSE
AND I CAN SAY THAT DEFINITIVELY
SHE PRESENTED HERSELF AS A
ROTHSCHILD.
IN FACT, SHE SAID SHE WAS GOING
TO HER GRANDPARENTS' HOUSE THE
EVENING BEFORE WE PLAYED GOLF TO
PICK UP HER GOLF CLUBS.
>> Reporter: THOSE GOLF CLUBS
WERE USED TO PLAY AT NEARBY
TRUMP INTERNATIONAL GOLF COURSE
THE DAY AFTER HE SAYS HE MET HER
AT MAR-A-LAGO.
THIS PICTURE FIRST OBTAINED BY
THE PITTSBURGH POST GAZETTE
SHOWS HER POSING FOR PHOTOS WITH
BOTH DONALD TRUMP AND SENATOR
LINDSEY GRAHAM WHO WERE AT THE
COURSE HOLDING A FUNDRAISER FOR
THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
>> HER INTERACTION WITH TRUMP,
YOU KNOW, WAS FIVE SECONDS AT
MOST.
SHE WAS VERY GOOD AT ACTING LIKE
SHE HAD BEEN IN THOSE TYPES OF
SITUATIONS BEFORE SO SHE WAS NOT
STAR STRUCK.
>> Reporter: IN THIS VIDEO
OBTAINED FROM THE POST GAZETTE
YOU CAN HEAR A GUEST OFF CAMERA
JOKING WITH HER THAT SHE COULD
AFFORD TO PAY $1 MILLION FOR A
PHOTO WITH TRUMP.
>> ANNA, YOU'RE A ROTHSCHILD.
YOU COULD AFFORD A MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE PICTURE OF YOU
AND TRUMP.
>> Reporter: NOTICE SHE MADE NO
ATTEMPT TO CORRECT HIM.
HER LAWYER TOLD US SHE WAS IN A
LOCATION WHERE PEOPLE THOUGHT
SHE HAD MONEY AND THAT NO ONE
WOULD BE SO QUICK TO CORRECT
THEM.
ANOTHER VIDEO FROM THAT SAME DAY
SHARED WITH US BY THE PITTSBURGH
POST GAZETTE SHOWS HER AT AN
EVENT AT THE DPOFL CLUB WHERE
SHE SAT JUST FEET AWAY FROM
TRUMP WHO WAS AT THE PODIUM.
AFTER THAT GOLF TOURNAMENT ON
MAY 2nd, 2021, THE WOMAN
ALLEGEDLY POSING AS ANNA DE
ROTHSCHILD WENT OUT FOR DINNER
WITH A GROUP OF TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
THE PITTSBURGH POST GAZETTE
SHARED THIS PHOTO WITH CNN.
THAT'S HER IN THE BACK STANDING
BEHIND DON JR.'S FIANCE.
THE MAN STANDING ALL THE WAY TO
THE LEFT IS JOHN LA FEV WHO TOLD
ME HE FIRST MET THE WOMAN AT THE
MAR-A-LAGO POOL.
AND THE WOMAN'S LAWYER ALSO
CONFIRMED SHE ATTENDED A
FUNDRAISER FOR FORMER MISSOURI
GOVERNOR ERIC GRIETENS DURING
THE SAME WEEK HELD AT A PALM
BEACH MANSION OWNED BY TRUMP.
WE REACHED OUT TO TRUMP AND ERIC
GRIETENS AND LINDSAY FWRAM FOR
COMMENT BUT THEY DID NOT
RESPOND.
THE FBI ALSO DECLINED TO
COMMENT.
THE WOMAN'S VISIT TO MAR-A-LAGO
DOES RAISE ALL KINDS OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT SECURITY, GIVEN
THE CLUB IS ALSO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S HOME WHERE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS WERE
DISCOVERED IN HIS POSSESSION
BACK IN AUGUST
>> I WAS SURPRISED AT HOW LITTLE
THERE IS IN TERMS OF REAL BONA
FIDE CHECKING OF WHO COMES IN
AND OUT OF MAR-A-LAGO.
MR. TRUMP IS NO LONGER THE
PRESIDENT BUT HE IS A MAN
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT AND HE HAS
ALL TOP LEADERS FROM ALL WALKS
OF LIFE.
>> Reporter: FORMER SECRET
SERVICE AGENT JOHN WHACKROUT
TOLD ME SECURITY AT MAR-A-LAGO
LIKELY DIDN'T DO A BACKGROUND
CHECK ON THE WOMAN AND THERE ARE
DIFFERENT LEVELS FOR THE CLUB
VERSUS THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
RESIDENCE.
THE U.S. SECRET SERVICE REFERRED
US BACK TO MAR-A-LAGO.
SO WHO IS THE REAL ANNA DE
ROTHSCHILD?
HOW DID SHE GET PAST SECURITY?
WHAT WAS SHE DOING AT
MAR-A-LAGO?
>> IF SHE IS NOT THE WOMAN SHE
SAYS SHE WAS WHAT WERE YOU ABLE
TO LEARN ABOUT HER?
>> SHE WAS BORN IN A SMALL TOWN
IN UKRAINE, POOR, SHE CAME OVER
HERE WITH HER FAMILY, AN
IMMIGRANT FAMILY, FIRST
GENERATION.
HER FATHER IS A TRUCK DRIVER IN
SUBURBAN CHICAGO.
HER MOTHER CLEANED DOCTORS'
OFFICES.
>> Reporter: THE WOMAN'S LAWYER
ANDREW SMALLMAN TRIED TO SET THE
RECORD STRAIGHT AND TOLD ME THE
ONLY TIME HIS CLIENT WENT
THROUGH THE SECURITY GATE AT
MAR-A-LAGO WAS ON MAY FIRST LAST
YEAR AND THAT SHE DIDN'T SHOW
ANY I.D.
ON MAY 2nd HE CONFIRMED SHE WAS
AT THE BEACH HOTEL ACROSS THE
STREET.
ON MAY 9th AT THE FUNDRAISER FOR
THE GOVERNOR.
HE TOLD ME SHE IS NOT A SPY.
HE PAINTED HIS CLIENT AS AN
ABUSED WOMAN WHO WAS BEING SET
UP BY A MAN SHE FILED A
RESTRAINING ORDER AGAINST.
HER LAWYER SAID THE PASSPORTS
WITH HER PHOTO AREN'T REAL.
THEY'RE PDFs AND THAT SOMEONE
CREATED THEM WITH HER PICTURE ON
THEM.
THE WOMAN'S LAWYER SAYS SHE IS
COOPERATING WITH THE FBI BUT
WOULD NOT COMMENT ON THE
INVESTIGATION.
>> JOINING ME NOW FROM PALM
BEACH COUNTY, WHAT DID THEY
ACTUALLY INVESTIGATE?
WHERE DOES THE INVESTIGATION
STAND NOW?
>> Reporter: ANDERSON, THE FBI
IS STILL APPARENTLY
INVESTIGATING THE PITTSBURGH
POST GAZETTE REPORTER TOLD ME HE
HAS SPOKEN WITH AT LEAST FIVE
PEOPLE WHO TOLD HIM THEY WERE
INTERVIEWED BY THE FBI.
I REACHED OUT TO SECRET SERVICE.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE MUCH TO SAY BUT
HADDISH UNITED A STATEMENT TO
CNN SAYING IN PART THEY PROVIDE
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF PERSONAL
SAFETY AND SECURITY.
THEY ALSO NOTED IN THE STATEMENT
THAT THE MAR-A-LAGO CLUB IS
SEPARATE FROM, IT IS A PRIVATE
CLUB AND SEPARATE FROM TRUMP'S
RESIDENCE OF COURSE AND DIRECTED
US TO THE ORGANIZERS A THE CLUB
TO ASK ABOUT ACCESS IN TERMS OF
WHO GETS IN TO THAT CLUB.
BUT NO QUESTION, ANDERSON,
SECURITY IS A CHALLENGE THERE
GIVEN IT IS A PRIVATE CLUB AND
TRUMP'S RESIDENCE AS WELL.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THIS WOMAN
SHE WAS ABLE TO GO THERE AND
JUST BREEZE RIGHT PAST SECURITY,
NO QUESTIONS ASKED.
SHE DIDN'T SHOW AN I.D.
ACCORDING TO HER LAWYER AND THAT
RAISES A LOT OF QUESTIONS OF
COURSE BECAUSE YOU KNOW AT THIS
TIME THERE WERE THOSE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS IN TRUMP'S POSSESSION
AT MAR-A-LAGO IN HIS PERSO